jumana el ali and her disabled son have
lived in this camp for internally
displaced people for five years
like many others in syria at the
province they rely on food and medical
aid from abroad
sometimes we receive those eight boxes
and sometimes i sell it to buy bread or
vegetables i'm a widow with a disabled
son he needs medication there's no one
to help me
international aid is transported by road
from neighboring turkey through the
bubble hawa crossing
every week hundreds of eight trucks
crossed this border behind me into
northwest syria to help more than 4
million syrians have been displaced in
their own country
the aid accounts for up to 80 percent of
their food supplies
the need is large only international
bodies like the un can help to contain
famine inside syria
the ukraine war has pushed up wheat and
fuel prices and reduced donations aid
groups say a fair and systematic aid
distribution is impossible without the
un's involvement
we don't want our people to suffer a
humanitarian catastrophe or famine this
possibility would cause a massive exodus
to turkey
moscow has threatened to veto un8
deliveries from turkey since 2014 but
there's no other viable alternative to
the bubble hawa crossing and if it was
to be restricted eight agencies say
millions of lives would be at risk cnm
ka solo al jazeera at the turkish-syrian
border